Peter you and Yusuf
you and Youssef were really on the
ground floor of this amazing movie we're
about to see and I know Youssef you said
you read the script on a plane and you
immediately related to Harold and
besides wondering if you really ever
were that dark and mischievous I have to
ask you what it was like to visit the
set of Harold and Maude as you did in
San Francisco yeah it's true I was dark
and mysterious at one time that's why I
was looking for the light so hard but
you know when I first came onto the onto
the set you know I saw this first time I
met how you know I've never seen a
picture of this guy before I thought
like a guru not proper film director I
thought but and he was smoking these
little cigarillo things and and
something else went for many things but
and then I heard the song and you know I
just got brought into his world and it
was a great with San Francisco blue sky
and on the set there was Ruth Gordon and
bud cort it was just so amazing and and
I had a couple of songs and he wanted
something original and that's and I went
into Wally Hyder studios in San
Francisco cut these things which I
always meant to re-record properly but
we never did because he wanted the film
out you know and and they got stuck
there like demos and that was that the
guy involved
you